600 accidents de chasse depuis
l'ouverture plusieurs morts des dizaines
de blessés graves dimanche dernier un
homme tue son fils un garçon de 14 ans
on n'a jamais vu cela depuis que la
chasse est devenu un sport démocratique
et que des milliers d'amateurs en ont
fait leur distraction du dimanche plus
grave encore il ya quelques semaines un
industriel parisien monsieur le comte et
tué dans des circonstances mystérieuses
personnes parmi ses compagnons de chasse
de ceux désignant comme responsable
lieux du drame heudicourt dans l'eure
alors voilà je suis au service
de monsieur richard je suis son corps
j'ai insisté
enfin j'étais pour ainsi dire pour
raisons là clients alors voyons vous
étiez à quel endroit au moment où ça
s'est passé mais nous étions tout près
du château de dicko et vous vous maniez
le rabat la batterie moi je me lève à
voter oui alors vous avez continuer à
arpenter le terrain puis tout d'un coup
vous êtes arrivé alors qu'est ce que
vous avez vu c'est à dire que c'était au
bout d'un certain moment oui ils ont ils
ont fait le docteur et un docteur sur ma
gauche
dr pistor ils ont dit ils l'ont appelé
quoi alors sans savoir pourquoi puisque
moi je croyais que c'était pour rire
agit bien de décès du coup qu'il avait
un bon chien on dit qu'à l'appel docteur
piste ho avec son chien
pour l'heure c'est le gibier pire moment
après j'ai entendu arrêté labatut un
blessé j'arrêté la bâtie et puis au
bénin pied un petit moment on a vu un
petit rassemblement que la victime était
tombée
vous savez pas où il y avait quelqu'un
on il ya un blessé
j'ai pensé dit certain qu'ils étaient
plombés ces règles sévères du moins
dupes l'ombre comme ça arrive quelques
vives et puis là on arrivé là bas j'y
arrive et qu'on mettait en finisse et de
métaux voiture peut l'enlever
c'est tout ce que j'ai vu sur le terrain
l'occident paraît invraisemblable
[Musique]
on chasse en plaine à découvert
la ligne des tireurs à l'affût et à plus
de 250 mètres des rabatteurs et pourtant
un homme est touché
alors monsieur le comte était à ce
poste-là n'est ce pas été ici exactement
le jeu richard le président klaus a tiré
de la haute levade 275 m et la voilà
tout à fait personnelle de la chasse
canton l'aiment c'est passionnant même
et surtout sans le romantisme de la
littérature spécialisée sans la poétiser
et sans l'aïr il reste qu'elle est avant
tout une ambiance un climat notre propos
n'est pas ici d'engager un débat le
gibier garde toujours sa chance
vous allez le voir dans un instant on
peut être pour ou contre
comme on est pour ou contre les courses
de taureaux mais là n'est pas la
question
aujourd'hui on tue aussi des chasseurs
pourquoi
[Musique]
ouah
[Applaudissements]
zéro
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bravement face à la ligne des tireurs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
hazard
quoi qu'il en soit en l'état de la
législation peut-on faire quelque chose
des chasseurs répondent et bien dans les
battues en principe quand on parle
surtout à l'ouverture de la chasse ou
c'est dangereux c'est dans les
betteraves par exemple dans tous les
couverts tout le monde un peu le sang
chaud le jour de l'ouverture
alors quand on arrive à certains moments
qu'on a poussé les perdreaux dans les
couverts sa part de tous côtés
alors les gens ont tendance à pas écouté
alors c'est là à ce moment là que je
commence à rentrer en ligne d'hier il
faut tout de même et freiner un petit
peu mais alors ça freine les gens y a
des moments ça va pas toujours tout seul
mais c'est ce qui évite en principe les
accidents dans ces conditions quelles
sont à votre avis les mesures de
sécurité indispensable il faut prendre
lorsqu'on chasse en collectivité comme
vous mais je crois qu'une des premières
précautions et de ne jamais conserver
les cartouches en dehors des battues
dans son fusil
très souvent un chasseur peut en ayant
conservé des cartes aux gens son fusil
appuierez actionné la gâchette et
provoque un accident c'est à votre avis
le précepte numéro oui évidemment mais
ça c'est sûr et en plus il ya une chose
très importante à mon avis c'est la
façon de tenir son fusil mais à peu près
deux façons de tenir son physique
correcte à mon avis c'est de tenir cassé
sous son bras ou alors fermé et comme ça
sur l'épaule c'est ça une façon
extrêmement dangereuse que de tenir
comme ceux ci est balayé parce que
marseille c'est une chose qu'on voit
assez souvent
j'appelle d'ailleurs la face on
assassine on voit les une mare du canon
qui se promène son voisin c'est très
très agréable précautions les plus
élémentaires c'est quand on voit une
pièce de gibier il faut la laisser filer
si on n'est pas certain d'avoir le champ
libre et de pouvoir tirer
monsieur j'ai une idée je ne sais pas ce
qu'elle vaut évidemment rien ne
ressemble plus à une cartouche
ordinaires qu'une cartouche qui tue une
cartouche ou une balle mais est-ce qu'on
ne pourrait pas différencier la couleur
carrément faire que tous les armuriers
se mettre d'accord pour avoir une
certaine couleur qui serait
par exemple noir et qui montreraient que
c'est ou de la chevrotine ou une balle
parce qu'on peut très bien se tromper
quand on a dans une dans une
cartouchière deux espèces monsieur vous
êtes chasseur vous avez été au courant
comme tout le monde de cet accident de
10 courts
quelle est votre opinion bref j'ai
l'impression comme plein c'est
extrêmement difficile d'avoir un
accident grave de l'accident qui n'était
sans doute provoqué par une erreur d'un
chasseur qui a dû mettre une ballerine
chevrotine par erreur mais en plein je
ne trouve pas que la chasse soit très
dangereuse je pense effectivement que le
chasseur si c'est un accident est dû
confondre deux cartouches en les mettant
ensemble dans ce centre où chacun pioche
arrive parce que les gens sont trop
nerveux n'ont pas été habitués à la
chasse tout petits à suivre les jeunes à
savoir comment ça se passe savoir qu'un
fusil tu es si ça tue le gibier ça peut
être mais les gens de même façon
personnellement en chassant il m'est
arrivé d'être tout seul dans la plaine
avec mon frère s'embête de moi un jour
de temps couvert
un perdreau part entre nous deux je vis
mon perdront n'étaient que 2 j'ai quand
même plombée mon frère et vous même avez
vous été victime des émois moelle est en
rabatteurs
dans une chasse organisée comme la nôtre
en arrivant près pas tellement loin de
la ligne des affûts j'ai reçu un coup de
fusil
je me suis couché pour le deuxième qui
me passait au dessus de la tête mais
j'avais trois plombs dans le front enfin
si ça avait été drogué il c'est pareil
c'est bien qu'on soit entre amis on n'a
jamais su nous le coup de fusil était
parti vite et si par malheur et vous
arrivez un accident par et quelle serait
votre attitude je sais pas mais
traitement et
il n'y a absolument aucune hésitation
sur ce point sont a provoqué un accident
il faut immédiatement intervenir au
point de la victime
président de chasse arrête la chasse
quand je crois que dans ce domaine il
n'est pas question de dissimuler
l'accident si c'est invraisemblable
quand je dirige mon frère on était tous
les moyens je me suis né j'ai été
dénoncée mais quand on est en équipe
organisée c'est quelquefois bien
difficile de savoir
ah ben moi je c'est à dire que je vous
dirais que je n'aurais pas mis le turbo
6 ou de balle d'abord j'ai bien que je
n'aurais peut-être pas dit que c'est moi
qui avais tiré parce que je n'aurais pas
su que j'avais mis une chose at il une
balle donc c'est une chose absolument
je crois qu'il me semble normal facile
vous aviez provoqué un accident je
l'aurais dit immédiatement et rim est
arrivé d'envoyer dès que tu arrives et
d'envoyer des plombs des camarades je
savais très bien que c'était moi qui
avais envoyé les plans que je disais que
c'était moi ça n'avait pas de jeu ne
souffrez pas l'ombre d'une hésitation
est ce que les risques grandissants
qu'on rencontre à la chasse vous amènera
un jour ou l'autre abandonner votre
sport qui semblait s'être sport favori
certainement pas parce que
personnellement je suis très prudent il
m'est jamais arrivé quand même de de
faire du mal à nos prochains articles de
sport sabeg a malheureusement il ya un
bout de temps que je sache c'est mon
premier permis à l'âge de 16 ans et je
cherche toujours avec des amis très
est-ce que le fait que les accidents se
multiplient vous amènerait abandonné la
chasse un jour ou l'autre au nous
sûrement pas ou ne recule pas non je ne
crois pas parce que j'ai la charge
depuis c'est pas moi depuis 13 14 ans je
vais à la charge tout le temps je n'ai
jamais cessé sauf comme de chirac
pendant la période de l'occupation
j'aime la chasse le risque
me gêne pas si vous voulez mais est ce
que vous avez peur maintenant à la
chasse non je n'abandonne ne riez pas la
chasse à cause des risques
ah non non mais si je faisais un
accident je crois que j'apprenne à
l'achat
[Musique]